[Musique]
le César du Meilleur jeune espoir
masculin est attribué à robinon Stevenin
merci à mon
père merci à tout le monde merci pour ma
pomme et
puis et ben à bientôt je sais
[Musique]
pas le César est attribué à Julie de
pardu
pour merci beaucoup je je suis pas
tellement un espoir comme je l'ai déjà
dit mais apparemment ça n'a pas été
signalé donc j'ai quand même 30 ans il
s'agirait de le notifier j'ai des pases
doigt si
souris donc non enfin ça me fait
plaisir voilà mon
fardeau merci Gérard de pardu
etard ise le César est attribué à
Guillaume de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pardieu n'était pas parmi nous ce soir
alors je me propose de me le garder
perso afin de l'inviter à venir me le
demander avec amour et l'actrice ce soir
qui prend le pouvoir et bien c'est dans
un second
rôle Julie de
B oui vérifions quand même ton père non
il est
parti le César est attribué à Emma de
[Musique]
côe tu es pour rien rassure-moi hein tu
es pour rien
non ben merci beaucoup beaucoup bah je
suis je suis très contente merci le
meilleur eSport masculin est attribué à
Louis Garel dans les amentss réguliers
qu'est-ce qu'il faut que il faut que je
dise des trucs là dites ce que vous
voulez alors vous êtes libre d'accord
alors je peux commencer par exemple par
ce que je ressens là oui je suis content
et je voulais dire aussi bonjour à
claudtin ma partenaire de jeu à Philippe
qui est réalisateur du film que je
connais bien
et et à ma mère maman j'ai pas le bac
mais j'ai mon César merci beaucoup tout
le monde au
[Applaudissements]
revoir
merci le césard du meilleur acteur est
attribué
à Vincent casselle bon je vais faire
comme tout le monde je vais commencer
par
euh par par remerci monsieur Claude
Berry mais pas pour la même raison que
les autres parce que grâce à lui et
Thomas
Longman et puis comme je me suis dit que
ça risquait d'arriver quand même j'y
croyais ce soir j'ai demandé à Monsieur
lev Kim de préparer un petit truc pour
[Musique]
moi
allons chez Théodose qui est-ce c'est
mon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oncle
je viens de ça et je lui donne ce
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
César